hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis l'accord de rochers noirs alger
sinon toute l'algérie a retrouvé le
calme peu à peu la rue avec le retour
progressif des musulmans dans les
quartiers européens a repris son aspect
d'autrefois
le photographe de la rue à réinstaller
son inventaire
les deux communautés timidement d'abord
on commençait à réapprendre à vivre
ensemble
pour la population musulmane
à huit jours du scrutin
d'autodétermination
la campagne du référendum est du reste
la grande affaire sur les murs sur la
chaussée le mot indépendance s'est
multiplié
pendant ce temps dans l'algérois le fln
a poursuivi ses réunions
à larbaâ 50 km d'alger au milieu de
vingt mille personnes si mokhtar le chef
de la wilaya iv a pris la parole des
slogans tous aux urnes mais aussi pour
les européens vivons la main dans la
main
à paris le général de gaulle accueillait
le 12e des présidents des républiques
noir d'expression française en visite
officielle en france monsieur david
dacko président de la république
centrafricaine
un dîner de gala de démarquer à l'elysée
la visite de trois jours du benjamin des
chefs d'état africains monsieur tacot
n'a en effet que trente deux ans il
rapportera dans sa lointaine patrie le
souvenir d'une france après avoir été
tout élève reste profondément amical
[Musique]
à la gare de l'est le premier ministre
monsieur georges pompidou est allé
recueillir le chancelier fédéral
d'autriche monsieur gorbachev une
question au centre du séjour à paris de
l'homme d'état autrichien la possibilité
pour l'autriche pays neutre d'une
association au marché commun
nous
evian a été le rendez vous des
professionnels de la presse la biennale
internationale de l'information célébrer
le dixième anniversaire de sa création
au cours de cette manifestation le
secrétaire d'état à l'information me
suis à l'interface a remis la coupe d'or
à monsieur claude valeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce qu'elles ont toujours été
considérés comme les ambassadrices de
charme et de l'élégance française il
était naturel que les hôtesses de l'air
fussent conviés en voisine à
l'inauguration de la nouvelle usine de
la beauté qui viennent s'ouvrir à
chevilly-larue la beauté on le sait est
en france l'un des premiers articles
d'exportation et la parfumerie figure
dans le peloton de tête des industries
exportatrices les deux tiers de sa
production partout pour l'étranger
situé au près de ce carrefour du monde
qu'est orly le nouveau complexe
industriel verra ses produits s'envoler
vers 129 pays où ils sont distribués
dans 10000 points de vente quand on
parle de l'élégance de paris on pense
d'abord à la haute couture la parfumerie
avec ces modernes usine où la côte est
se prépare aujourd'hui à l'échelle
industrielle en est l'une des
propagatrice les plus puissantes
[Musique]
chaque année c'est la même chose à
diemeringen en hollande on à la
troublante sensation de voir double
précisons tout de suite qu'il convient
de l'incriminer aucun abus liquide dans
cette affaire ni moyenne et simplement
le lieu de rendez-vous annuel des jeunes
300 jumeaux autrement dit 150 paires de
congressistes de tous âges se sont
retrouvés cette année
à
où
que dire de ce progrès sinon qu'il
favorise évidemment les dédoublements
par la formation de couples parfaitement
identiques reste que pour être semblable
les jumeaux n'en ont pas moins des
tempéraments différents on le vit bien
cette fois lorsqu'il s'est agi de danser
le twist
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les hommes ne sont sans doute pas des
ingrats puisqu'ils étaient plus de 60000
à longchamp où un prix paris pour
admirer lors plus noble conquête ce
n'est pas celle que vous croyez on a
certes beaucoup regardé ces jolis
chapeaux mais c'est pour les chevaux
qu'on a réservé son enthousiasme sous
les sabots de l'un de ses chevaux la
fortune sur les 3000 mètres du parcours
il ya là de quoi rendre cardiaque des
milliers de parieurs de fait après
quelques foulées la moitié des
spectateurs de longchamp a déjà des
palpitations val de loire le grand
favori est triste il n'a pas envie de
courir il est bon dernier
dans la dernière ligne droite il essaie
de se rappeler qu'il est le meilleur
cheval du lot il est alors un peu tard
pour retrouver la joie de courir et
c'est armistice un brave cheval à qui
personne ne pensait qu'il file vers
l'arrivée c'est un miracle il est mené
par un jeu qu'est boiteux gens de forges
qui le dirige vers la victoire de forge
en effet il n'y a pas si longtemps était
cloué sur un lit d'hôpital après un
terrible accident
c'est sous cet équipage bien sympathique
plus à bas la pluie d'or réservé au
vainqueur du grand prix
[Musique]
lors de l'apothéose par dizaines de
milliers les brésiliens le président
vous larhantec sont venus accueillir les
champions du monde de football à
l'aérodrome de brasilia le brésil en a
oublié tous ces soucis et tout son
enthousiasme comme à l'heure du carnaval
c'est à ces champions qui le réserve
pour les peler les santos lady di cette
ultime épreuve est plus redoutable que
la finale de la coupe du monde ils sont
tous les mains tact corse qu'ils
arrivent au palais présidentiel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette petite voiture qui a attendu l'été
pour éclore c'est le dernier modèle de
la régie renault la r8 elle est tout à
fait différente de sa grande soeur la
dauphine elle est plus spacieuse et
aussi plus confortable c'est la première
voiture de grande série dans le monde
qu'ils soient munis de quatre freins à
disques autre avantage pour le
conducteur étourdi avec son moteur
sierra la r8 n'a pas besoin d'eau en été
pas plus que d'antigel pour les grands
froids et si le coeur vous en dit vous
avez le choix
les 24 heures du mans se prépare d'abord
dans la coulisse au paradis des
mécaniciens une nécessité absolue pour
préparer la victoire le réglage des
parts et la vérification de la l'humain
sur la part cédé reposent les chances
françaises ne pas oublier non plus que
le moteur ça déborde lui et voici
l'envers du décor ici ceux qui ne se
doute de rien ceux qui sont là pour
s'étourdir en regardant passer les
bolides sans se rendre compte de
l'effort qu'il a fallu pour mettre les
voitures au point ces voitures elles 155
vont essayer de tenir pendant 24 heures
en roulant à tombeau ouvert
et c'est le ballet des voitures qui
cherchent à se faufiler pour s'assurer
dès le début la meilleure note
pour l'instant c'est un autre ballet
celui de la kermesse là c'est le circuit
les spectateurs où l'on consomme autant
de liquide qu'une ferrari
les beaux châssis il n'ya pas seulement
sur la piste
mais sur la piste on laisse à peine le
temps au spectateur de pouvoir c'est à
près de 300 à l'heure que les bolides
fonce dans les lignes droites en
attendant la nuit c'est un chassé-croisé
perpétuel entre les paires harry les
aston martin et les masses erratique des
monstres qui développe près de 400 jeux
en petites cylindrées une voiture
française domine le lot si la part cds
dérivés de la pl 17 de monsieur tout le
monde elle tourne avec régularité 101 à
coup en orbite des grosses voitures
[Musique]
et quand la nuit se termine il ne reste
plus beaucoup de voitures en cours sur
55 il n'y en aura que 18 à l'arrivée
tour à tour les aston martin les
maserati ont cédé le pas à la ferrari
numéro 6 de fil il est jeune de bien la
victoire finale revient à la ferrari
mais la petite foire cd pilotée par
guillaume à hébertot prend la première
place à l'indicé de performance c'est la
10e victoire de pas un roman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]